i got off the airplane laughing and
chatting with the australian
guards i was slammed upside the wall
by border protruding eyes forward eyes
forward kicking my legs apart
putting handcuffs on me so hard to cut
the blood off leg irons
iron as far as and they want me about a
hundred yards
turned me over to the marshals the
marshals took some of the
leg irons and stuff off chained me to
the wall and left me there all day
then they took me to the metropolitan
detention center on conair
no i was just in a van there was los
angeles they took me to metropolitan
detention center in los angeles
and put me into isolation i said what in
the world am i in isolation for
i've done nothing and i was there three
or four days and i talked to the
lieutenant when he come in the morning
he said
nothing i can do for you reeves so
there's a guy came there and he was in a
suit
nice looking fella he opened it up he
said hello reeves i just want to see
what you look like
my name is uh associates
warden short and i saw your national
geographic documentary with me
and it does me pleasure to keep you in
isolation
and he shut the little judas window and
that's the last i saw i never could get
out of there
so i stayed in nine months without a
hearing
which the parole board has to give you
one within three months they never did
give me one
i paid a lawyer seventy five hundred
dollars his name was uh
cannon up in san francisco
uh he never once made a phone call never
and somebody got to him
what was his name mighty christopher
cannon
christopher christopher cannon the
lawyer in san francisco that the pro
board said don't touch it
and he stole my 7 500 and never made one
phone call
bastard i mean thoroughbred thoroughbred
yeah wow so what was the documentary he
was talking about
national geographic come down to
australia and they did one only called
australia's hardest prison and they did
one
uh and i got some some action in that
one because i was looking for that
online i couldn't find i saw something
on that on a history channel
they take it off after a while i
understand national geographic does and
they put it back on
it was real big at one time okay yeah i
remember searching for it and i couldn't
find it
i got a copy of it okay i've got several
copies of i could see in one of on it
so how long did you end up staying in
los angeles metropolitan they sent me to
um they sent me on conair
to uh oklahoma and there i got put on
the show
floor but i had to report to the officer
every two hours or they was going to go
back in the shoe
so i was i couldn't believe it and
i just saw the corruption of the conair
and whoever whatever congressman senator
jones at
i bet oh yeah explain that people from
wake cross georgia
albany georgia jacksonville florida and
they got caught with two grams of
something
three grams five grams they facing five
years and they
mentally probably little problems with
mental
a lot of prisoners do and they were
being sent to los angeles
for psychiatric evaluation and it takes
about three months to go and a month or
two to come back
and they stay in oklahoma and they go
from one place to another on conair
until they finally get
to some doctor in los angeles that says
that they have a problem or not
and then i met the ones from los angeles
and san francisco
and they were going to atlanta georgia
to have psychiatric evaluation
so no matter where you got busted for
these small-time drug offenses they
would find
a psychic or a psychiatric uh
psychologist on the opposite end of the
country so they could shuffle you back
and forth so they had
a reason to fly conair all around the
country it's just
blatant ripping off the government
that's as bad as obviously who owns
conarry
i might be back in prison that's
interesting
who can you find out maybe on google
like who owns conair you would think
that would just be part of the blp right
no somebody owns it the other bop
wouldn't be doing that how many
how many uh airplanes do they have does
is i saw three big jets there's three
jets
and then they got a lot of that's all i
know but that that tower in in
uh oklahoma which is center it's got
1800
rooms and those planes are landing and
coming in there day and night
it's just like grand central station of
federal prisoners
why are they moving them like that i
don't know
somebody's making big big money whoa
that is kind of wild i had no idea about
that
yeah he's trying to inch it over
you just double click the top yeah it
probably won't tell you the truth
fleet size 59 parent company
con air group inc headquarters
abbotsford british columbia canada
they have 59 planes conair group inc so
it's a corporation
yep whoa they own some politicians i
guarantee you oh
yeah they're uh
wow man wow that's [ __ ] that's
how what year did you get out i got it
last year
last year you got out 14 months right
now
wow man
wow i stayed in another nine months it
was harder than the 18 years
in australia in isolation here for
parole violation from 1977
for possession of marijuana that
somebody was after me they wouldn't let
the lawyer
talk and they wouldn't let me out of
isolation
so what happened after you were in that
nine months isolation in los angeles
they let me out and i went home and you
were a free man no i was on parole and i
didn't know how long i'd be on parole
but you were at least you were able to
go home my wife and and
the covid was out and the parole
officers didn't come and so after
a year they said we dropped their parole
you're free i got my passport i got my
driver license
i got my pilot's license wow
i'm ready to go wow man what an
incredible
fascinating story so he went back and
got my pilot
uh polish license and went and went went
down and rented a plane for a day
i had a good time so what's your goals
now what's uh what's what's next for
roger reeves what's next on the in the
uh
what's the next chapter for you i just
don't know what's going on i'm gonna
take it one day at the time i'm just
happy to be home with mark no more plane
loads of marijuana no
that's over over the horizon radar
oh that's incredible you and your wife
uh
the bond that you guys were able to form
and the the
the way you guys were able to stay
together for that
long period of time even though you were
gone for 30
33 yes years is
this is so amazing i never heard of it
i've never heard of it
i've never heard of that i mean it's
rare you hear of that with people that
don't didn't go to prison
yeah let alone did have to be isolated
for 33 years it's just done
it's just unbelievable she waited that
long what is the key what what's the
what's the
what's the secret what's the secret tell
me the secret she's just a she's a
christian person she's
lovely i mean she's just like too good
for this earth
i said what did you tell them are you a
beautiful woman she said i told him
i'm not available and said that worked
yeah so bless her heart it waited on me
all that time i tell y'all when i came
home
there was the same table a round oak
table that i'd sanded in
and there was the same placemats that i
had left 35 years ago
last thing there was the same silverware
in the same place
i just sit there and cried just like oh
just just it took me three days i
couldn't even look at pictures of her
when she was 40 and when she was 50 and
when she was 60 i wasn't there
yeah so how did it make you feel made me
feel sick
still i don't like to look at the
pictures and i was going that many years
half of my life i was in those prison
cells
it just was oh maybe
i certainly i broke the law in my outlaw
but
i'm not much of a criminal i don't i
don't hurt nobody i'm
i'm for good in this world just uh
just got caught up in this and did it
[Laughter]
yeah